throughout all the different levels of
boot camp people drop out did you get to
the actual war zone and notice a person
didn't have what it takes at that point
oh with the team that I had no does it
happen yes one of my best friends went
to Afghanistan and they had this dude
who passed all the training they were on
this hike up the mountains in the snow
he quit right there he just dropped this
Brookside he's like I'm done in
Afghanistan in Afghanistan during a
mission platoon sorry like you're
finishing this thing after you finish
this we're gonna send you back again
kicked out of the unit and you're gonna
get sent to the big army you're gonna
get article 15. what's article 15. if
you get in trouble in the military say
you got a DUI or you beat your husband
or somebody like that you get this thing
that is just like a mark a bad mark on
your record and it's going to affect
your promotion status so you want to
make Sergeant you want to go higher
they're going to look at your records
did she say beat your husband yeah
so they don't like that either good